I think we're going to do some outgo
side work just for the morning on uh on
this new thing I've been trying
shot new Alo you're testing against
generalized advant Vantage estimation so
the goal is to kind of learn a form of
discounting by uh expanding the value
head to be like 32 dimensional or 64
dimensional or whatnot and predict the
reward for future time
steps I suspect something is still wrong
though because it's not learning the way
I would expect
yeah but there's only one head so it
predicts future discounted return and
then you have to tune a discount Factor
whereas if you were to just predict all
the future rewards directly you
shouldn't have
something okay so the mean tense are
learned
perfectly and then standard deviation
tensor
okay good so this does actually do what
we
expect it is learning a random a
reasonable standard deviation and a
reasonable mean so then the only thing
that could be screwy
here is the data could be wrong
yeah so reward block is already indexed
right
hang on I don't think that this is
correct is
it no hold on I might have something
here let me see if this is actually
correct so
self.
values so anything that gets passed in
is already sorted
but now this is going to be the wrong
shape isn't
I hate when my extension just breaks for
no
I
forgot this one
one of these times this is going to do
something eventually this is going to do
oh wait yeah it's doing
it look at
that mean is going to take a little
longer I think but uh actually no mean
should be that way standard Devi ation
tensor though look at that it's learned
uh it's going to learn its own
beautiful now this we're going to track
this
thing and it will learn its own
discounting we'll see whether it learns
it any quick any uh quicker
but we do have the thing
apparently there's a bug with some NS at
some
yeah it's weird that we have this we're
going to have to F uh figure this out
separately
okay so something is definitely we need
to fix this first before we can do
anything I
guess of course the second you don't log
it it works
somehow the standard deviation can
become Nan
screwy we had seen the time of life
though it does it is able to learn some
sort of BD
distribution so there is a chance that
if we fix this we actually get something
good out of this
I mean that is technically an out of
bounds right
standard deviation clipping screwing
this one I think
what's the issue with
G that it has two hyper parameters that
are environment
specific so you can't run the same thing
on multiple different environments and
if you wanted to say train um on
multiple environments at the same time
or something you wouldn't be able to
so it's a
fundamental problem with the
could I mean G is a hard Baseline to
beat right
but I do see that it is learning
appropriate variance terms so that's
pretty cool
even so that's fine and then the
variances should be approximating a
discounting factor
it looks like they are
moment there were a couple terms that
were
broken we'll fix those I just want to
see if we have the method doing anything
reasonable
yeah so far this is doing better than
any of the previous trials where I had
some stuff
broken um but it's nowhere near the uh
the J the tune J run yet
should at least do better than the
previous runs you would hope
loss so that's fixed the other the
previous
well that has done better at least than
the other ones
steps cuz I think there's still an issue
with the way that we're Computing things
here
but this could do something I'm going to
go up I'm going to do a couple things
while this
runs and I'll be back in a few and uh we
will continue on this for another hour
and a half or whatever be right
that it's hard to say which of these is
going to be better because like it's a
weird shaped graph but uh that's a way
higher amount than I've seen on any of
the previous ones and it looks like
you're getting a pretty reasonably
learned discounting as
I think I did a sweep before as well so
this is
definitely this is definitely a
reasonable
Baseline here we go oh actually yeah
this is substantially better thank you I
was looking at episode length
so uh blue is 32 Max Horizon or 64 Max
Horizon this is 32 Max Horizon and then
this is the g8e
Baseline now the thing is it should get
strictly better over a longer Horizon um
we just need to come up with a better
Advantage function is my
yeah this is totally fine
here this loss is good
so it's got to be the other
loss is the advantage
calculation which is right
here I'm just dividing by the standard
deviation right
now yeah this thing's got got to get
normalized
do I make the advantage
function reward minus mean over 1 plus
standard deviation
game wait you already wrote an
environment there's no way
oh you wrote out
the
okay I shouldn't put this on stream
right let me see
Okay cool so I mean I can look at this
with you
capacitor there are only two knobs here
right
oh yeah when you have two knobs like
this see these aren't even actions right
it's a one-step problem you're just
setting these and then running the whole
simulator like you could even it's
honestly easier to think of those as
just like you could like use a hyper
parameter optimization algorithm for
this frankly this is like so incredibly
simple cuz it's a one-step problem
like yeah you literally like the new
hyper parameter algorithm that I have
you can like throw just the hyper
parameter algorithm on without the RL
and that'll still work
well yeah the thing that's missing here
right is usually there's an interactive
element in RL
um but I mean it's I have tools for this
sure that's
fine well I mean you're you hit like you
make one decision you hit simulate and
that's the whole thing
right if you're playing pong you're
moving the paddle at every single
step it's not like a step simulator
mhm well it's just like it's not bad
it's just easy right it's just it's an
easy
problem yeah yeah you have a
two-dimensional optimization problem one
well yeah this is just good enough for
now
no it's
40 but the thing is it's not 40 just for
um
Brock they doubled the price so
presumably it was 20 for Twitter premium
before right and then they added 20 for
Rock so it's the same price as the
others
this is still incredibly stupid the
suggestion I just gave
me
all right that's good enough that's some
data um
deviations what are you looking for I'm
just trying to find a nice way to scale
the
so this is now going to scale the
advantages a little
better and this should actually make it
robust to longer Horizons as
well essentially what this now does is
the expected shape of the advantage
curve or the uh rather the standard
deviation
here stream go so the expected uh shape
of this curve
hard
Flatline and this is like
0.1 something like
this okay so this needs to
contribute zero and then this should
contribute like
one we just needed a normalization
factor
now we'll see if the one I came up with
is any good you know there's no
guarantee that the one I came up with is
any
good even though it makes
sense seems like it's under performing
for now maybe it catches up we'll
just a little bit behind I
think oh maybe it catches up
and then we also have one more
normalization scheme to try after this
as
H they should have like totally crushed
the
um no
there's something I guess just with the
uh the learning rate and heing that it
just can take off at some
816 can try normalizing I don't think
normalizing is going to do a ton for
this honestly but we'll try it just to
I'm out of thinking field for the time
being
let me just
see I mean I really this is like so
freaking basic but
wa can't I uh just
initialize the parameter
better log standard deviation
no it's because it sets the log standard
deviation to one to start
I it's just going to tell me to add
Epsilon as
no I don't want to do this why would I
do this
this whenever I'm doing like basic math
you'll watch like it takes me way longer
and then it
should
because I don't do it very often
frankly but
uh that's fine we get through it we make
the algorithm and then we make up for it
in engineering
so
silly stuck on something like
isn't this just the way easier version
of
it if we're deciding to not be stupid
it that draw to be
stable
okay again we have no idea if this even
helps but we'll run this and then we'll
run a longer Horizon and longer Horizon
should be strictly better so the trick
here right is that a property of this
algorithm should be that increasing
The Horizon should uh cause it to do
strictly better it should not be getting
confused by longer Horizon because the
standard
deviation will be flatlined at the point
where it can no longer have any
effective prediction that far into the
future and that gets subtracted out so
that has no effect on the
advantage a lot of problems are defined
by less than 100K parameters
uh what do you mean by
that
problems I don't know what you mean by
defined it would be are they solvable
with less than 100K parameters
right yeah okay so how large of a model
to solve it depends I think you'd be
surprised what you can do with less than
10 million parameters and uh you know
100K is perfectly good for doing very
very fast research we do a little larger
than this we go up to a million at
times
H it's promising
how does model SK size scale with IO
well that doesn't really tell you
anything either
right because there is a scaling factor
with that but you know 999 of those
inputs could be worthless or they could
just be linearly related in which case
you just need one layer to sort that
relationship out right so it really it
depends it depends mostly on the
fundamental complexity of the problem
not just the
it's just how hard is the problem to
solve that's pretty that's it like the
neural net is learning a function that's
mapping uh that's mapping inputs to
actions how hard like how complex is the
function required to solve the problem
that's all it is
yeah but it's
not there's not like
a you can't just fit Big O to it
right first of all there's no end to
scale it with it's like if you have one
simulation or another simulation one
problem or another like there's no
scaling complexity factor to a lot of
these things
it's just it's a constant it's a big
constant you're trying to estimate the
big
constant yeah of course each Sim scales
differently like the thing to look at
this is just like think about it at a
high level right they each different
problems some problems are easy some
problems are hard some problems are easy
for people to solve some problems are
hard for people to solve well some
problems are going to be easy for neuron
Nets to solve and some problems are
going to be hard there's not going to be
a onetoone mapping of which ones are
hard for which
either but gen generally right I can
look at something like Atari and say
yeah that's going to be an easier
problem to solve than DOTA and it's
going to require a much smaller neurom
man
but there's nothing to quantify over
right like you don't have any input
variables that describe the problem
they're each completely
different this is not like an algorithm
where you're scaling in and seeing how
you know how the complexity
oh yeah yeah yeah okay if you have an
existing problem right if you have an
existing problem that has an existing
known solve complexity or an algorithm
with a known solve complexity yes you
can use RL as a fast approximate
algorithm in some
valid that may that is
valid this is so freaking close for
close isn't that kind of cool though
with puffer though that like I uh I am
designing an algorithm to potentially
replace one of the most widely used
things in the field in the span of about
two days of work
XA scale level XA scale was big back in
2018 it's not huge
nowadays you can just go buy yourself a
pedop flop your
company what's it now uh 20
million they probably have overhead 100
million
there's no way this is going to
seriously do worse
right if this is going to do worse we're
going to have to take a look at our uh
our
formula I mean it should do better in
the sense that um
it should at least be trying to estimate
values that are farther
out it's getting more training
learned uh learned parameter yet
either layer we should try that
yeah yeah not per not amazingly stable
yet it's untuned though
and let's remember it is quite possible
though that we just run tuning and uh
you know just the optimal learning rate
has changed and stuff it's possible that
we match just off of tuning
and mind you the tuning will also be
quicker or or fewer samples rather
because we no longer have to tune Lambda
and Gamma they no longer
exist this is irritating me that this
doesn't seem to match quite well
though and there takes off
right little bit
well this is the whole algorithm right
is that you're predicting all the values
you don't need to learn a discount
Factor over values if you just predict
all of them
I mean these curves though are so
chaotic like it's hard to say
right yeah I'm not going to be confident
saying one of these is way better or way
worse than the other
here curves are pretty
chaotic do you have suggestions coming
to RL I have a full guide for
you I put all my suggestions for
newcomers to RL in one quick easy
blog there you go
we've trained uh several people actually
in RL that came in with no AI background
let alone you know uh deep learning
anything
else RL used to be incredibly incredibly
difficult to get into like really
freaking hard but we've made it a lot
easier it's only going to get easier as
well we're working on simplifying a lot
of the algorithms out a bunch of old
crap okay we're going to try this next
which is going to be learned standard
clo input not linear must be tensor not
linear
which conferences do you try to
attend well I went to
NPS um this January it nearly killed me
so I think we're going to be a little
bit more selective
NS I mean we're going to be more
selective about going to conferences at
all as I can tell you that was not worth
what I uh that was not worth it
your conferences don't have peer review
that sounds great
yeah we have notoriously terrible peer
review just
awful well I don't know what's happening
with the standard deviation of this
tensor
broken what didn't you oh uh I got
pneumonia at nurs and nearly died in the
hospital two weeks later that's what I
didn't like about
it conference was
fine but
how is it pushing this one to be crazy
negative
and wait how is it it can't have a
negative standard deviation that doesn't
make sense oh wait cuz I
didn't maybe I'm just being stupid hold
on yeah yeah so it's got to
be for. X
yeah yeah I Sugg just checking out that
link if you're interested in getting
involved in RL honestly building stuff
in puffer lib is the best way now to
give you an idea
all these environments are made by
contributors or most of them are I made
this one this one and this one the rest
are other open source contributors many
of them came in with no RL experience
let alone AI
experience
um yeah and they're all super fast
they're playable you can watch the
agents playing
them so it's a really good way to get
involved is just like building an rln
and training on it from scratch
okay this is way more reasonable
okay there we
go how do you make the most of your
graphics what do you
Game Dev Game Dev is fun Game Dev is
just that's just engineering X
right some of these are very very
simple the only asset here is a
puffer and then uh we also have we've
got stuff like this right that's a
little
prettier made an enin puffer puffer took
a little bit to get used to scon
integration sorry I'm looking for a way
around that but the problem is there are
really no good like binding options from
uh python to C I'm trying to find better
ones and is running over a million steps
that's what we like based on the ocean
example still need to figure out how to
get it training yeah so that's going to
be the uh learning curve bit uh the most
common problems are incorrectly computed
observations uh like not populating a
buffer correctly or like not handling
reset the way you think they are usually
those are the most common
yeah I don't know why this thing doesn't
seem to be training at all now with a
learned
standard deviation
tensor because the standard deviation
tensor looks good to
me and we'll let it see maybe it just
takes longer to take
off regardless
though I'm very very close
here what do you guys think does it make
sense
for the standard deviation of the
output to
be learned per instance or should it
just be a a
parameter so like basically should it
learn a per time step variance or should
it learn a per observation per time step
variance
instance how those two different well
you can either Define it as a neural
net. parameter so if there're 32 time
steps you're just going to learn 32
variables and then for every observation
you know you're going to get the same
standard deviation on them or you can
have the variance actually be predicted
by an extra head on the net Network and
then you can actually have the network
learn to predict when it's confident and
when it's not on each time step um it
doesn't seem to train though which is
odd because I'm looking at the standard
deviation tensor and it's pretty
reasonable looking to
me like that's a very reasonable looking
standard deviation
tensor so I don't know why it wouldn't
be learning e
oh it is learning it just took forever
to take like to start
huh that's
net CRI standard deviation one for the
value
it collapsed again
H very
awkward 01 on the action head then one
on the value
it's
crazy it
learns much
better and that standard deviation is
really important as
well it's being a lot more conservative
here where it's like not trying to use
predictions too far
out that's interesting
fine I don't know why this wouldn't
train the other one wouldn't train at
all it's very weird
works yeah this thing fundamentally does
not understand I don't know
job you shouldn't be anything
fundamental I don't
welcome I mean at some point you've got
to assume there's just a bit of variance
in the curves right I mean breakout is
known to have um a ton of
variance obviously it's there's still a
gap to G but uh these little tiny
tweaks I don't know if we're really
measuring differences between them very
much I do want to try uh I think 128
Horizon that would be a good data point
to have just to
see the idea is that with the current
implementation you should be able to
expand the Horizon and you should not
suffer performance penalty it should be
able to help if you're able to learn it
but if you're not it should not hurt
because the variant should essentially
be
zero 720
me yeah okay that's not far off that's
can I fix
this I forget one of them yeah I
did we'll make that a learnable
parameter as well
maybe or sweet parameter
and I'm just going to do this so we can
see
it it does look like it slows the
algorithm down which is not
great I don't think it
should finally your undergrad I want to
create finally your project in RL very
confused still I heard RL is still far
away from being used in real life no it
is used in real life the thing is it's
not used out of the box in real life
life it's kind of at a point where if
you have an application you got to go
hire some smart RL people um and you
know give them a couple years to make
sure they really get it working
but uh so it's not out of the box but it
is used now if you're trying to do like
you know a cool project that scale of a
thing yeah we have a lot of these things
so puffer AI here right we have all
these different environments that are
built for uh really fast training in RL
you can watch the agents playing them
live they go from very very simple like
this up to very very complex like this
miniature
MMO and uh you can kind of watch the
agents run around here and do different
things sometimes they get stuck but they
actually will if you watch them they'll
do some pretty impressive
stuff same with this
MOA you know we have it working in a
variety of different areas
won't get any job from RL well it's not
really an un like it's not really an
undergrad job is the thing right like
where RL is right now it's you're mostly
hiring RL
phds that's the tricky thing but
um General ml there's tons right like
it's all the same stuff there's tons and
tons of stuff in general machine
learning
it's pretty easy to just float around
from one sub field to the
next I mean I don't know your background
level right but if like we have some of
the simplest RL code out there so you
can look at some of the example
environments and the way we do stuff and
if you say oh yeah that looks like that
looks like something I can deal with
then you know you're set
I like this one this is massively
multi-agent
snake we can definitely get working it's
just a little takes a little
work right so here's the latest
one and yeah I so there is definitely
something going on with the longer
Horizon longer Horizon should not hurt
learnability but it looks like it is
right unless this thing is going to take
off massively
maybe it's just that you're getting a
little bit of
noise and
um we'll have to actually go look at how
much of the training how much of the
data is
noise I could clip it
maybe kindly suggest a cool project I've
done specialization in
RL from course I didn't even know they
had one of
those I mean generally what you do is
you pick
a simple game right you pick
like a simple game that we don't already
have you implement it take a look at the
way that we do stuff because you know we
do stuff in a specific way to make sure
it's very fast it's very simple the way
we do it um and then get RL training on
a new M so pretty much like showing you
can do the whole end to end process of
here's a new environment I implement the
environment I get the RL training on it
here's the agent that is trained on it
that's kind of what we uh what we
suggest to people who are relatively new
in
RL I mean a lot of these are not a
tremendous amount of
code I think that this whole thing is
less than 500 lines
32 yeah like 200
lines doesn't take a lot to do some
pretty cool stuff in
RL puffer Li tries to make it pretty
easy
Finance the one that people always want
to do is they always want to do like
Market
Sims I wouldn't say I wouldn't try to
simulate the actual stock market but I
will tell you that
like you can definitely do some sorts of
like trading type
simulators um I can show you like a a
very small thing that I've done in that
area well it's not a small thing it's
small because it's embedded in a much
larger
thing but here
like these agents if I just take over
for this guy real
quick I can like buy and sell stuff on
the
market um just like with key
presses so this agent can buy and sell
stuff with like hundred to ,000 other
agents in the same
environment so you can Implement some
sorts of like basic trading simulators
like that and then track uh track prices
track supply and demand that type of a
thing I think Salesforce had a thing on
this that was kind of
ridiculous RL
I mean they were doing it for tax policy
which was kind of
stupid um but where is
it where the hell did this the all the
images for this thing
go yeah so they were doing stuff like
this where they had the simulation and
the Agents like could trade and stuff I
wouldn't try to embed them inside of an
environment I would just do the trading
portion you know like agents have
certain amounts of
goods agents you know produce different
quantities of different Goods agents all
need a certain quantity of different
goods and then see if they can learn to
trade with each other
efficiently that type of thing is pretty
straightforward e
okay so this definitely hurt
performance I question is
why it's got to be noise it can't really
be anything but noise right
ah and actually it's not slowing stuff
down either it's just the uh the wrapper
is apparently
slow that's fine we'll fix that that's
no
here going to have to hit continue a
whole bunch of times
until uh the standard
deviations get to a reasonable
distribution I'm trying to think in the
meantime what else it could
be I would think it would have to just
be it would have to be the
advantages I mean there's just nothing
else right
okay ah shoot it's going to eat all
those continues isn't
there we are
okay so
Z we're capturing
90% about the first half
uh which is not enough because clearly
there's nothing else after
it but the thing is how do you how would
you clip it
all right we'll see how that goes be
right
well this is weird isn't
it is this still not doing well
could also figure out the miscellaneous
time what's going wrong there
I mean the standard deviation tens are
here right
like it's only maybe the first
16 somewhere between 16 and 32
elements that actually are are
finish but this doesn't seem to be doing
what we
want we could just test this at uh
32 length but I think that we're leaving
performance on the table
thing is I can't think of why that
wouldn't
um clip clipping this
should
prevent anything SC from happening in
the advantage I guess it could just also
be the loss is really noisy the uh the
value function loss is really noisy but
I don't think that makes
sense if I look at the value
loss right so this is our value loss
here and yeah it's going to be higher
but it's not
I could also just zero the second where
everything after 32 is a
comparison because that should
definitely work right and if that
doesn't work then there's definitely
something
we'll double check that to speed up our
training
RS but this is going to be about the
same if not a little
HTML un
[Music]
interestingly this is
fine for
maybe this just gets ported to see or
something I don't know this is weird
regardless though
right we should be able to
this and if this doesn't fix it then
there's there something else I'm
missing cuz this should make it the same
as the 32 one
shots I think this is still
underperforming isn't
say I mean we're not going to be able to
tell for a while
if this matches at least then we'll know
that the issue is
in the way that we're handling uh
clipping or whatever
that and also why clipping doesn't seem
to do enough
oh no maybe it is I okay we'll let it
we'll uh we'll
see if this matches then it tells us
directly
that the issue is just uh the variance
post processing
case take this as an opportunity to
commit the current
is there a reason to expect this to do
better than
previous I think not
really I think it should just about
I mean that actually seems like there's
policy damage right that's not just
random
variation in getting a bunch of bad
samples I would
expect that actually would be another
good topic for uh for research why the
hell our curves are such a
mess e
no that would that gives you these
little squiggles down here right these
are just sample by sample squiggles but
when you get stuff like this this is
actual policy damage right like these
are not random action sampling this is
like it's like something screwy
happened hey
fact that it's not m what we had before
concerns
me
oh okay maybe it is just end
behavior with one un monkey Spike yeah
okay
fine at the very least there is a
substantial Gap just caused by the way
that we're handling
that I think we can
probably handle these things separately
though
right CU if all I do is here I think so
I want to go get lunch and do some
exercise so I think what we're going to
be uh
32 and 32 this should be the stable one
and now we no longer care about Gamma
and Lambda
right take these out
entirely now we're just tuning this
stuff really the one that matters the
most is going to be like learning rate B
size
okay little time steps do we have in
here
fine we will just leave this on as is
let's make sure that this actually
trains
just get rid of
this so like leave this scale like this
well I think what I'm going to do from
now on
is when I have like cool new research
like this I might not share it on
Twitter like in post form uh so you know
there will still be a decent little
surprise for the general audience but
yeah if you're on the stream you just
get to see whatever the heck I'm
currently
doing because I think this will be a
really cool result if we can get this to
match this would be huge
and let's go take a look at this one
here oh yeah that's way closer to the
original curve now it's got this this
dip but yeah there's definitely
something screw with the longer Horizons
we'll figure that out though there's no
big deal there we'll figure that out for
sure and then it'll just do even better
already do you get a bunch of
emails uh yeah they just go to spam
though
I mean even then it's just not a good
use of
time okay cool so quick summary of what
we have right now we have a stable
implementation of this generalized
Advantage estimation free po
that with completely untuned
hyperparameters uh gets pretty
close to the original with
j and well not completely untuned it was
the old ones that were tuned for J so
then the question is going to be whether
we can match this via hyper Prem sweep
alone or if we need to keep working on
the algorithm quite a bit
I I'd honestly be surprised if peer
review is even directionally correct in
AI is
this I don't think I could have broken
anything here okay I think we're just
going to leave this to run because we're
probably just spending time analyzing
random noise
here yeah if we're able to do this then
basically we will have we'll have
removed two hyper parameters which you
always have to sweep which are really
annoying uh it will have the potential
to do better because it will be able to
have a flexible Horizon that changes
over the course of learning which should
be important in more complex
tasks
um and it will allow the algorithm to
work more robustly uh across multiple
good and yeah this is close to on par as
well now with before you can see yeah
look at
perfect cool so I'm going to go get some
food what do you decide to do I just ran
shorter Horizon for now for the sweep
what current ocean M can we use to test
learning over an Adaptive Horizon any of
the more complex ones your one
potentially Spencer's one neural MMO MOA
any of the more complex
ones in fact I know how to uh Captain I
have a a perfectly good way to to track
that as well uh it will be very easy
we'll add a metric for logging it like
literally all I have to do is get this
thing to be about on par with G and then
we can do lots of cool stuff well when I
say all I have to do it that would be
like that would be like a giant RL
contribution so we'll see how hard it is
but uh it's going pretty well I think we
need to run the sweep to see how much
we're missing out on
that will
be nicely set up for
goes you could initialize new tensors
yeah there's a lot of stuff we can
fiddle with same policy for all not
exactly same policy it's just that this
will these are two of the hyper
parameters that are the most
fiddling right and that vary the most
across environments so if we remove this
then it means that we'll have a PO will
work way more out of the box than it
currently
does I think we'll have to change the
name from pop to P30 puffer proximal
policy
optimization but uh I'm going to go
while this sweep runs I'm going to go
get some exercise I'm going to go get
some food and then I'll come back in the
afternoon we'll look at this we'll
probably have to work on a few other
things as well because you know I have
contracts that Demand work as well but
uh this is this is pretty
solid uh so thanks folks and and uh if
you're interested in any of this
stuff that I work on here it's all open
source
puff. start the GitHub really helps us
when people start the GitHub two more
people join the Discord to hit a
thousand that'll be pretty nice and you
can also follow on X where I post a lot
of RL content got a Blog as
well so yeah other